- I surrender.
- (clapping) Yeah.
- You guys, (beep) this
test, this is horrible.
(upbeat music)
- We have a 16 year old who is
taking 'em very soon, right?
- Yeah, she's super stressed out about it.
- My son has taken a PSAT so far.
- My son just took it, and
P.S. it was really hard.
- When in doubt, you choose C right?
- We read a passage, and
we have to answer questions about it.
- My emotions are complicated,
not readily verifiable.
Like who's emotions
are readily verifiable?
- I'm already zoning out.
- And what I do is both a challenge
to my egotism and a surrender to it.
(exhaling)
- Deep (bleep).
- It's very teenangsty.
- And a lot of needlessly large words.
- I don't even want to read
it, that's why I'm skimming.
- Okay, which choice
provides the best evidence,
for the answer to the previous question?
- Oh my gosh, really?
- I have to go back and reread it?
It was painful enough the first time.
- I don't know, I don't even want
to think about that question anymore.
Moving on.
- [blonde hair] Oh my God.
- [brunette] Oh.
- That passage was obtuse,
to use an SAT word.
- Two wrong, eight right.
- I only have four correct, it's very sad.
- (laughing) I didn't even
fill out the form properly
because I'm missing one.
- This is writing and language test.
- Grammar Nerd Heaven.
- People be oppressed and including the
- Now, that's bad.
- Included
- So, Sarah wants to add more words,
and I want to delete the whole thing.
- I took me a minute to
understand actually what they were
asking the question.
- [Dark Hair] Yeah,
what are they asking?
I don't understand.
- As an adult, I've learned
that if you don't use
proper grammar, it makes
you look really stupid.
- We both got seven out of nine,
we got the exact same ones.
- A couple of them were tricky.
- Four wrong, I'm never
gonna live this down.
- I got three wrong, so six right.
- When you get in that
testing environment,
you start to second guess.
- Math test, no calculator.
- I'm sweating.
- I'm having anxiety,
just like looking at this.
- I feel like I have to
say, math is important kids,
but it's really not.
- Which of the following expressions is
equal to zero for sum value of x?
- I don't even know what
the question is asking me.
- Like the names of people
I went to kindergarten with,
I can recall, no problem,
but what expression is equal
to zero, for sum value of x?
- What's the point of the
- What ever happens, it becomes
positive no matter what.
- Literally, nothing you
just said made sense to me.
- Oh my God, I don't want to
subject my children to this.
- 10 divided by zero would be, 10, right.
- No, I don't think so.
- No, I got it wrong 'cause
if I had gotten it right,
the answer would be one half,
but that's not a choice.
- Do we have to divide the whole thing?
Like do we
- [Blonde] What, no.
My brain, I cant.
- No.
- Five, out of six.
- Two, out of six.
- I got two legitimate answers right,
then I got two right by guessing,
for a total of four.
- I'm trying to think of like a time after
you get through college,
when you really have to sit
and be so focused, for so long.
- It's horrible, it's so hard.
I'm an adult now, math,
and I don't use this,
in my life, math.
- I still don't like testing period
- Never make me do that again.